things you can't see but you're defying
angles that's all those scentsy done
was he defined angles so
so when
in the example where you um
yeah
i can't push it
what i'm doing is i'm blocking his
forward
angle
and i'm making i'm dissipating all his
power
in
in another direction to what is the
optimal illusion of everybody seeing him
going that way
so instead of it going the way if i was
trying to stop him the way like danny
was if i was trying to stop him going
that way my hand's going to either go
round or go like that with him
if i take hold of it
and i extend it that way but without him
seeing that that physical i can't
physically do it because he's too
powerful so i just think it and i go
down a little and in
my mouth
my mass i'm doing this with my mass and
once i've got him then i can almost take
it off and
do that because i've
i've locked him so once he's locked
so first of all it's it's mass
he's locked
then i can move about
and just put it on there and it won't
move because
he's locked himself without knowing it
so even though you're seeing a physical
push his mind is nowhere
to be him
to be his own mind
good
that's good
so you get feedback
and you work trying to work out now
how you're getting feedback and what's
happening
well i feel we've got two opposing
angles
yeah so you're you're defying an angle
but you're actually defining it mentally
without knowing it
because
you'll know